loon as in lunar and a loon and
mathematics looks something like this
and is that like the modern word for
that that's what you owe this what we
would call it I suppose
yeah looks like a crescent to me
Crescent you could call it that
well this is a mathematical object that
was of interest a number of millennia
ago and it's still of interest we we
have a real sense of what hippocrates of
Chios 5th century BC a mathematician he
was interested in can I say even though
this doesn't occur in his text at all
squaring the circle so what does it mean
to square the circle what it means
really is to find at least the way I'm
going to interpret it is to find a
polygon of the same area as the circle
and to find it in some constructive
manner what the Hippocrates was
interested in doing was finding the area
of such figures in terms of the area of
polygons he wanted to construct a
polygon that had the same area as a loon
as some loons he wasn't able to do it
for all or even in some sense very many
but he certainly was able to do it and
here's the starter loo starter loon
begins with making an isosceles right
angled triangle and here's the right
angle and thinking of that triangle is
being inscribed if you wish in a
semicircle the next thing I would like
to do is make another circle with this
hypotenuse as chord well I want to take
either one of these snippets of circles
but either this one or that one they're
both equal area and equal shape I'm
going to try to view this line as the
chord of a circle so that the figure I
make will be similar to this one or that
one I'm going to try because this is not
all that easy but I'll try to do it ok
um so these 3 dashed things are similar
let me draw it a second time and enlarge
now now the question is what we say
the area this guy in terms of the area
of the sky or equivalently in terms of
the area this guy because the last two
guys er have the same area well if you
remember the Pythagorean theorem this
length is the square root of 2 times
either of these leg so if the linear
measure is the square root of 2 of this
of the big segment is the square root of
2 times the linear measure of the small
either of the 2 small segments what's
the area of the big segment in terms of
the area of either the small segments
it's the square of the linear ratios
okay so this is twice the area of this
twice the area of that another way of
saying it is this area is the sum of
these two areas so suppose I start with
that triangle and I'll draw it again and
I remove this blob this area and now I
have to add something to keep the area
of the triangle the same and what I'm
going to do is add the two small blobs
so what does that mean that means that
the area of the triangle is the area
between these two semicircles so what
does Hippocrates done if he's done that
he has in some funny ways squared this
particular loon this is a loon s squared
he hasn't squared G Triangle bit he's
polygon that if you wish no that's not
where he ends his investigations because
he clover died it's already pretty
clever I think of this is the starter
construction this it's not clear in the
manuscript by the way or the text that
one has from his manuscript whether he
starts this way and this is his
inspiration but how can it not be this
is surely his starter loon construction
the minute you do that you might imagine
going into the
this of squaring or triangulating or
polygon dating as many loons as you
possibly can let me start with the
construction essentially with this
straight line so I'm going to make this
the cord of a number of circles same
line but the cord of different circles
so it could be the cord of the well
could be the cord of a hope I'm going to
draw it convincingly as a circle such a
circle that's not the best circle I've
ever seen or it could be the cord the
same line could be the cord of this
circle now every time I think of this as
the court of a circle I get a pie slice
of that circle I draw the line from the
center to the two ends of the cord and
there's my pie if I do it here the pie
slice would be pretty big this is a
rather generous portion of pie how do I
get our loons
well we got our loons by taking the same
cord and making two circles with that as
a cord of different radii and there by
getting two different pie slices okay
like this so that's so that's that's
good that's going to be big I guess and
like this and that's going to be
somewhat smaller and where's the loan
here and uh here's my lumen now what
turns out in each of hippocrates
constructions is he's constructed his
cord and his looms in such a way that
the area of this loon is exactly equal
to the area of this little what should
we call it polygon with a little conch
spokane is in spearhead and how does he
do this well by ingenuity and he
produces a number of examples he does it
by a certain process would be too long
to give in this numberphile but he does
it uh quite beautifully hippocrates
managers to construct situations where
the area of this pie wedge is equal to
the area of this pie wedge and so
therefore they have a common area which
is this
and that implies that this area is equal
to this area it is a consequence of a
very careful choice of the radii of the
two circles given the court there's a
serious mathematical question which can
be phrased in modern-day mathematical
vocabulary it becomes a question in
Galois Theory has Hippocrates
constructed all or perhaps almost all of
the possible constructions
given his methods has he found all the
loons that can be spearheaded his spear
spearheaded wonderful word and what's
the answer did he did he find them all
well this is a conversation any modern
mathematician can have with a 5th
century BC mathematician I don't know
the answer I worked on it a little